on Tuesday Broncos coach Vic Fangio
addressing the issue of racism in
society he he tried to make a point and
he made it in artfully and I'm gonna
read to you Chris what he said and then
what he said on Wednesday to clarify the
situation he said I think our problems
in the NFL
along those lines are minimal we're a
League of meritocracy you earn what you
get you get what you earn I don't see
racism at all in the NFL I don't see
discrimination in the NFL we all live
together joined as one
for one common goal and we all
intermingle and mix tremendously if
Society reflected an NFL team we'd all
be great I believe what he intended and
I think his clarification gets to that
that when you have your team identified
there there's no discrimination within
there you all are tied together but
there are well-established
well-documented issues within the NFL of
potential racial bias we were just
spending time a couple of weeks ago
talking about a broken system of
minority hiring that right Vincent the
executive vp of football operations will
willingly publicly say is broken so that
there are issues and there was a
backlash at Vic Fangio a strong backlash
he was one of the top trending topics on
Twitter yesterday as people saw his
comment I don't see racism in the NFL
and to his credit Chris he quickly did
what he could to clean it up after
reflecting on my comments yesterday and
listening to the players this morning I
realized what I said regarding racism
and discrimination the NFL was wrong
while I have never personally
experienced those terrible things
firsthand during my 33 years in the NFL
I understand that many players coaches
and staff have different perspectives I
should have been more clear and I am
sorry outside of those lines both in the
NFL and society there's a lot of work to
be done in the areas of diversity and
providing opportunities across the board
for minorities look when you make a
mistake when you misspeak right own it
that's how you clean it up and and it
didn't come off as contrived it doesn't
know what the nice man I gotta get the
heat out of a hot kitchen and and he the
moment that they realized in Denver
what was going on the moment Fangio real
is that the point he was trying to make
was not made with the clarity that he
intended he fixed it now look they it's
it's it's different than drew brees
because I don't think there was any lack
of clarity but for Fangio he painted
with too broad of a brush he felt the
reaction Chris and he did what he had to
do to clarify his point yes exactly
right and clarify his point also with in
going self reflection and then also
saying hey I talked to players on my
team and that shows a guy that's
compassionate and well thought-out and
willing to listen to to go that was
stupid that I said that yeah I think Vic
Fangio when he said the comment he is
trying to talk about a locker room more
and more than anything and you know a
locker room in the NFL is not reflective
of society yeah you know there's a lot
of blending and cultures it's the great
thing about football
it's the reason I tell parents to this
day hey get your kids in football not
only is it gonna teach them a lot of
life lessons I've been around a lot of
different cultures and learned a lot
about these different cultures because
of my football background and got to
experience things that yes and my white
privilige life of growing up in North
New Jersey that I would have never
experienced if I hadn't just stayed
there and not played the sport of
football so you know within the locker
room there are great respects you got
people coming from many different
avenues of life and different struggles
and you find a way to unite and be good
and that's great but the bigger problem
where I think Vic Fangio missed out in
the combat is yes as in totality in the
NFL we know there's definitely issues as
far as you know the minority coaching
racism whatever it may be I mean again I
just I'll bring up Eric the enemy how
he's not a head coach right now I don't
get that hey Jim Caldwell look I mean
he's twelve games over 500 as an NFL
head coach he brought the Detroit Lions
to the playoffs twice I mean the Lions
that they they they can't go to the
playoffs with anybody else he's been a
Superbowl coach he's fired
he's not even talked about as a head
coach in the NFL I mean that's insane
that just tells you that there is an
issue in the NFL altogether
so yeah good job by Vic Fangio I know
what he was trying to say his comments
weren't nearly as insensitive I think as
Drew Brees is but it was a good job by
him taking the situation head-on and
addressing it and reframing his words
and his thoughts and showing some
compassion about the subject
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports